- Look what they're offering us now?
Their answer is, "Okay we've
removed God from the equation
and what do we get?"
We get government.
And they now pray basically to government.
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
- Wow, thank you very much.
That is a great welcome.
Thank you so much.
Well welcome tonight's "Big Conversation,"
filmed live here in
Costa Mesa, California.
"The Big Conversation" is produced
by Premier Christian Radio in partnership
with the Templeton Religion Trust
and it's a series of video discussions
between thinkers across
the religious spectrum,
looking at some of the
biggest questions in life.
Who are we?
What's it all about?
Looking at science, faith, philosophy,
what it means to be human.
I'm delighted to say that tonight
we're going to be sitting down
and hearing from two people
I've really been looking forward
to bringing into conversation together.
We're gonna be looking at
the question of is God dead?
It's a conversation on faith,
culture and the modern world.
Where are the next generation turning to
in an increasingly post-Christian society?
"Is God dead," as Nietzsche once declared?
Or is there space for a
renaissance of religious belief
in the modern world?
John Lennox, who is here on my
left, is emeritus professor.
Yeah give him a round of applause.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Just to give a brief info,
John is emeritus professor of mathematics
and the philosophy of
science at Oxford University.
He's a leading Christian thinker
and he's engaged many
of the world's leading
atheist voices as well.
His latest book is called,
"Can Science Explain Everything?"
And it is available as well after.
Dave Rubin is my other guest.
Let's have a round of applause for Dave.
(audience applauding)
Now Dave hosts the "Rubin Report."
It's an online talk show
that reaches millions
of people every week.
Dave is gonna be telling us
about his religious background
and where he's at now.
So I won't sort of label him at this point
but he regularly hosts conversations
with leading cultural and
religious thinkers on his show.
So I'm really looking forward to
and he's going to be bringing
to this conversation today.
He has a new book out it's
available for pre-order,
"Don't Burn This Book," is the title.
(audience laughing)
Thinking for yourself
in an age of unreason.
So I do recommend you go and get that
if you can on pre-order as well.
So one more time just
please give a warm round
of applause to my guests,
John Lennox and Dave Rubin.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
Well, welcome gentlemen
both tonight's discussion.
I'm really looking forward
to what we're gonna be covering tonight
because I've had you on
the show before, John,
and very often I've
put you in conversation
with maybe a quite firm atheist,
someone like a Dawkins or
an Atkins or a Michael Ruse.
But I think tonight's gonna
be a little bit different
because I'm really looking forward
to hearing your story, Dave.
We haven't met before, in fact,
tonight was the first time
but I've watched your stuff and
I've seen some of the people
that you've increasingly been talking to
and being influenced yourself
and it'll be fascinating
to hear where you're at now
in terms of both the cultural
and religious aspects of your worldview.
- Well, I've never had
anyone give me an intro
and say we'll label him later.
(audience laughing)
So I'm feeling really
undue pressure right now
and I'm the only one here from SoCal,
so let's see what happens.
- Well, whatever those labels may be,
I'm really looking forward
to what you're gonna bring to us tonight.
Perhaps we'll start with
you first of all, Dave.
Tell us a little bit about
who you are, growing up.
I know that you came from
a pretty religious family.
So do you want to tell
a little bit about that
and where you found
yourself as you grew up
and as regards sort of faith and so on.
- Sure, first off I just want to say
what a pleasure it is to be here.
You know, I'm usually on the
other side of the interview
and the reason I'm particularly
excited about tonight is
that I don't talk about this sort of thing
from a personal perspective that often.
You know I've sat down
with tons of atheists,
Sam Harris and Michael Shermer
and Peter Boghossian and that whole crew.
And I've talked to
plenty of people of faith
like Bishop Aaron and Rabbi Wolpe
and plenty of other people that come
from different political perspectives
and personal perspectives.
And I always find that
I go into each interview
with no agenda other than
hearing their thoughts
and seeing how that shakes
out around my worldview.
That being said, I'm excited to be here
because I can sort of
tell you a little bit more
about where I come from
and sort of where I'm at.
So I grew up in a conservative
Jewish household in New York.
We kept kosher.
We did Shabbat on Friday
nights, all the big holidays,
but there was a strong
secular belief within that.
And as I was telling
you sort of backstage,
you know there's an interesting
piece related to Judaism
that I think is a little
different than other religions
in that the ethnic tie to
it, at least in a modern way,
is for most Jews more important
than the religious nature
of it, specifically.
Let's say beliefs specifically.
Because John, as we were talking about,
there are many, many Jews,
especially in sciences and in mathematics,
that aren't believers per se
but have a real cultural affinity
and I would say that
that's sort of where I'm at
or at least where I've been
over the last couple years.
I actually am now in the last few years
and this has to do a
lot with being on tour
with Jordan Peterson for a year.
Jordan and I did about 110
stops in one calendar year
in about 20 countries.
It was pretty amazing.
And when you spend that
kind of time listening
to a true innovative thinker,
I mean truly the guy that I think is
the world's most important
public philosopher, let's say.
You know, talking about
his biblical lectures
and talking about his perspective on life
and that there has to be
a bedrock of something
that is real and true outside of us
and then how he relates that
through the biblical stories.
it moved me, it moved me
over the course of the year
that we did this together.
So I would say I'm secular
basically in my life
but I definitely in the
last year have found
that there has to be
something outside of us.
The rest of this makes no sense.
I mean the part, very briefly, the part
that you know I'm really known
for is the political part
and that I was lefty and the
difference between leftism.
- [Justin] You kind of
had a political conversion
of sorts, yeah.
- I had, right.
So I'm usually much
more comfortable talking
about my political conversion
than a religious one.
But I would say this.
That consistent with me talking
about sort of what's happened
with the postmodern left
with the progressives and we see this now
where there's sort of nothing
that's empirically true
and any given day you can feel anything
about any particular topic,
there's a reason for that.
And the reason is they've
disconnected everything.
Their whole worldview is disconnected
to anything that came before them
so that that could be God
or a religious set of ideas
or something like that.
So I'm really, really
fascinated by that at the moment
and it's changing how I live my life.
I just did, it was Yom Kippur,
which is the holiest day in Judaism.
I was at a service that
was actually at a church
in Pasadena in Los Angeles
hosted by Dennis Prager
that I'm sure many of you guys know about,
Dennis Prager, who many of you know.
So I'm sort of, I would say I'm in it
the way you guys are all in it,
trying to find some truth in the madness.
- I'll be interested to tease that out
a little more in due course.
I mean one thing I did notice is
I have seen just watching
some of your videos
that there definitely been a progression
in your thinking on this.
And probably if you go back a few years,
I think you had said,
along the lines of you probably thought
of yourself as an atheist.
But evidently that's not
quite the case anymore.
- Well I had a bunch of
atheists, high-profile atheists,
on the show in a row.
Starting with Sam Harris,
who I admire and he's
a good friend of mine
and Michael Shermer and Peter Boghossian.
And I really love the
intellectual side of that.
I really, really do love it
and that's not at the exclusion
of anything else actually.
But what I found was
that I had had a series
of atheists on in a row
and then people online just kept saying
that I was an atheist.
- Right.
- And then I sort of just
said it one day without,
it didn't mean anything to me
sort of one way or another.
It was almost, it just sort of came,
it just sort of came
out of my mouth one day.
And then two years ago,
you know I do this
off-the-grid August thing
where I literally lock my phone in a safe
and I don't look at
any news or television.
I am completely offline
and I really disappear
and I try to let my brain reset.
And two years ago when I did it,
one of the thoughts that
I kept having sort of
in my peace was that I'm not an atheist.
And I came back and I said
it in a very casual way.
And I just did this live stream
where I just sort of
said it very flippantly
that I just don't like the word atheist,
it doesn't fit what I believe.
I do believe in something else
even if I can't completely
articulate what it is.
I think Jordan has gone a long way
to articulating the type
of thing that I believe in.
And I got a lot of hate for that one
because you know the atheists,
they don't like a converted person either.
So, you gotta watch out for that too.
So you know we all have our own trappings.
But what I'm most interested
in is talking to people
from all walks of life and figuring out
what the common stuff is.
And what I like to frame
that around is a conversation
about freedom and how
do we limit government
so we can all believe
what we want to believe
and think what we want to think
and be part of a society
that's pluralistic
and decent for all of us.
- John, let's have a bit
of an introduction to you
for those who aren't familiar with you
Tell us about your own faith
journey up to this point.
You now obviously speak to many people
all over the world about Christianity.
But where did it all begin for you?
- It began for me, and let me say as well,
how delighted I am to
be back in Costa Mesa
and I've enjoyed in the
past some marvelous shows
with Justin and I'm just fascinated
by what's gonna happen in
the conversation tonight.
But I grew up in Northern Ireland
which isn't always the best
start to discuss religion
because it was a divided community
and there was a lot of
terrorism that was connected
in a very complex way to Christianity
of both versions, Protestant and Catholic.
But the important thing was
that my parents were very unusual
for that kind of cultural context.
They were Christian, convinced Christians,
but they weren't sectarian
and that was very unusual.
My father had a small business.
We lived in a small town, 15,000 or so
and he tried to employ people
from both sides of the community.
Now why did he do that?
I once asked him.
I said, "Dad, it's so risky."
And he was bombed for doing this.
My brother nearly lost his life.
And he said, "Look," he said,
"I believe that every person,
"whatever they believe,
is of infinite value
"because they're made in the image of God,
"going back to the Hebrew Scriptures
"and therefore I will employ
across the community."
And that has stuck with me.
And it's been very important
when you're discussing,
as I often do, with people
that do not share my worldview,
that always comes to my mind.
Here's a person in front of me,
and it relates to what you
were saying about freedom.
I would connect with freedom value
that here's something
outside of my parents
that gave every human
being dignity and value.
That was point number one.
The second thing was that
they allowed me to think.
Now Northern Ireland's often associated
with religious bigotry,
extreme fundamentalism,
all this kind of thing.
And my parents were not highly educated
but they really gave me space.
So my first encounter
with Christianity was
not mind closing, it was mind expanding.
And I remember when I was about 13,
my father came along, he says,
"Here's a book you need to read."
It was Marx's "Das Kapital."
I said, "Dad, have you read it?"
He said, "No."
(audience laughing)
"So why should I read it?"
"You need to know what
other people think."
I never forget that.
It was, set a compass bearing.
The third point is their
Christianity was credible,
morally credible, they actually
lived what they believed.
So in that sense I had a
hugely privileged background
that didn't compress me into
a narrow-minded bigoted person
and it was noticeable when
I went to Cambridge in 1962.
Not 1862, I know I look old.
(audience laughing)
But when I went to Cambridge in 1962,
many of my contemporaries from Ireland,
the moment they got out of the country
that was the end of any Christianity
because they'd never made it their own.
They'd never thought about it.
But I'd been encouraged to think about.
And that sort of set the compass bearings.
There's one further point
that really shaped my life.
I was challenged in
Cambridge, very early on,
by student at table at night.
And he said, asked, "Do
you believe in God?"
And then he said, "Oh sorry, sorry, sorry.
"I shouldn't have asked
you that, you're Irish.
(audience laughing)
"All you Irish believe in
God and you fight about it."
And I'd heard that many times
but somehow it was different.
And I thought, gosh yes, you know,
I've never really met atheists.
You know in Ireland people divided
the Protestant atheist
and Catholic atheists.
But they're not really real atheists.
So I thought, what I'm going
to do is to start today
and befriend people, befriend
them that's important,
that do not share my worldview.
And I've spent my whole life doing it.
So that really sets the scene I think.
- So Nietzsche famously
declared, "God is dead."
Now he may have been a
bit premature in that
but maybe he's finally, you know,
his thoughts are coming
true in 21st century West
because we are living
in an increasingly
post-Christian age, people say.
Increasingly the number of people
who tick the census box that says none,
no religious affiliation
is going up and so on.
I mean you're engaging with
this kind of demographic
all the time on your show, Dave.
What's your feeling?
Do you do feel like people are
genuinely less religious now?
To what extent are some of those friends
that you made early on in your show,
people like Sam Harris
and another well-known
atheists responsible
for people moving away
from the religious bearings
that they once had?
- So obviously I don't
want to speak for Sam
or any of those guys.
What I have found in the conversations
that I've had with non-believers
and with believers is
that at a micro level
you can be a non-believer
and be absolutely moral
and decent and good
and a productive member of
society and all of those things
as I believe those couple
people that I mentioned are.
What I think is becoming the problem
and I think this was really
where Jordan Peterson hit on something is
that societies can't organize around that.
That it can sort of work for a while
and there's you know most of
the things that I believe in
and I talk about the
individual all the time
and why I believe that
classical liberalism is
the best sort of framework
for a political system
that we should have.
They almost can't exist without
that underlying bedrock.
And so your question sort of gets
to what I was saying earlier
which is that the reason
that the secular world feels
so out of control right
now, I mean just yesterday,
I'm sure some of you guys saw that CNN did
this quality Town Hall last night.
And it was like you know everyone has
to mention their gender pronouns
and you have to admit that
there are more than two genders
and all of these things
that we know these
conversations are not being had.
There are settled science debates
that went on for a long time
that we know what facts are
and yet we find because this
has now become untethered
to anything other than how you feel
that now everything is up for grabs.
And that's why it sort of feels like
that there's something sort
of godless happening here
or something like that.
Now trust me that is a hard thing
for someone like me to say.
As someone that really my
beliefs really are rooted
in the Enlightenment and
the Enlightenment thinkers
and this a real debate amongst people
who talk about the Enlightenment.
Could they have done it, could
they have reformed religions
and burst liberalism in
a positive way forward
without some religious belief behind it?
I don't know the answer to that exactly,
I don't know that we'll ever
really know the answer to that.
But I would say that
the reason I first said
that I'm happy to be here
with you guys is that
in the last year where now
I've virtually only get invited
to events by conservative groups
or libertarian groups for sure
but groups on the right let's say
but I often get invited to churches.
I often get invited to places of faith.
Now I know we can go through a litany
of political disagreements
that we may or may not have
and I absolutely know that everyone
in this room would be happy to do that
and there would be nobody fighting,
there would be nobody screaming,
we could explore those
ideas as far as we can
and then we would put it down in front
and either agree to disagree
or maybe we'd move each
other one way or another
and that would be wonderful.
And I don't think that's a coincidence.
I don't think it's a
coincidence that you guys here
and that generally believers
right now are more tolerant.
They are, it's just the reality.
The people, yeah, give
yourselves a round of applause.
(audience applauding)
I mean that really is true.
Who are the most intolerant
people in society right now?
It's the people that are
constantly telling you
how tolerant they are.
(audience laughing)
That's the irony.
It's the people that tell
you you're a bunch of racists
and bigots and homophobes
and the rest of it.
And that's the real bizarre flip
that we have happening in society.
And I think that is linked to either,
however you want to phrase it,
either a post-Christian world
or a post Judeo-Christian
world or a postmodern world,
however you want to define that.
- I mean to what extent do you agree
with Dave's analysis
there of what's going on
especially I suppose
at that academic level
and in terms of the kind
of conversations now
that you are and aren't
allowed to have almost
when it comes to these issues?
- Well, I think it's a
pretty accurate analysis
and that's what I experienced right there.
I'm always interested in
the phrase "God's dead,"
because it seems to
assume he was alive once.
(audience laughing)
And of course I hear Richard
Dawkins kind of saying
which God and I think that's
a question worth addressing
because the God that I believe in
that is the God of the Bible is eternal
and that raises problems
for the deadness doesn't it?
- [Justin] Sure.
- But there's a sense
in which Nietzsche was
a very accurate prophet
and what to my mind is very important
with him was that he could see
where many contemporary
atheists cannot see
that if you abolish God,
you wake the ground under any solidity
on which you can base on
morality, human dignity,
freedom, all those values.
He saw that connection and he said,
if you didn't bring God you've
no right in the end to value.
So that you notice where
the values are real
out in our society they're
mostly values that go back
to the Judeo-Christian tradition.
And I think, therefore,
to bring that back into the discussion.
I like the idea and I think
it's very important start
where there's something more,
there's something outside of us.
That's the start, it seems to me,
of coming back to something
around which society can be organized
because otherwise
everything is subjective.
And you mentioned postmodern.
And it amuses me that
so many, but it's sad,
that so many of these people will tell you
as an absolute truth
that there is no truth.
Now that's just sheer nonsense.
(audience laughing)
- [Justin] Yeah because it's
a contradiction in terms.
- Yes.
- I mean you you obviously spend
quite a lot of time
speaking and especially
to actually a lot of young people.
- Yes, I do.
- Many of the events you do, John.
Do you find that there's a kind
of people are looking again
for a source of meaning,
for something to hold onto?
- Absolutely, I think that, well we,
it's country-specific because
there are parts of the world,
of course and where, for
example Christianity,
is growing like wildfire.
But in the UK and in the U.S.
I find that young people find the world
that is presented to them by people
like the old New Atheists or
the naturalistic philosophy
is too small to live in.
It doesn't give them any
kind of solid foundation.
So they're looking again.
And just what, last week,
I spoke to Central Hall Westminster,
1,500 young people starting
at the age of 13 to 18.
Absolutely fascinating
spending a whole day thinking
about these big ideas.
That I find enormously encouraging
when young folks start
asking these questions.
And I find a huge
response around the world.
But it's self selecting, you know,
it's very difficult for me
to give a global and fair assessment.
- I mean, it strikes me, Dave,
that you did this 100 city tour
with Jordan Peterson and it strikes me
that the crowds that have
flocked to hear him talk
about meaning in a meaningful
way have been quite young.
The kind of crowd that you kind
of might have expected more
to be turning out to hear the Sam Harris's
and the Christopher Hitchens
and Richard Dawkins and so on.
What's changed?
Why, in a sense, is the
conversation moved on
from well we all know God's dead to.
well what's gonna happen next, I suppose?
- Well it's really interesting
because if you were paying attention
to the media around Jordan during the year
the implication somehow or
the condemnation I should say,
from the media was that somehow this was
for young straight white men.
That he's only talking
to straight white men
as if inherently that's
somehow an evil thing, right?
So that was the idea that
somehow he's really broken
that straight white men are
showing up to his events
and that's somehow inherently evil.
Now of course that's absurd if, let's say,
he was talking to all
straight young white men,
if he happened to have been
giving them something positive
that could put a little
order in their life
away from the chaos as he would put it
that would actually be a wonderful thing.
Of course the irony is that
actually wasn't even true at all
because the crowds were
wonderfully diverse
and I usually thought they
were about 60/40 male to female
and age range all over
the place and all that.
But to answer your question specifically,
I think that we got,
as politics and the media
and social media and the fact
that we're all walking around
with a phone in our pocket
that has the world's knowledge
and you can connect with somebody
literally across the world
in a split second, I think we have no idea
how this information orgy basically,
I think we have no idea how
it's affecting our brains,
our ability to think clearly about things.
It's doing wondrous things, right?
We're all here because of
this, this a podcast, right?
We're disseminating this
through the digital world,
this is incredible but it
also has destabilized sort
of basic beliefs and I
think then Jordan stepped in
and said we have to be able to
get some meaning out of this.
So that's why he wrote "12 Rules."
He thought these are 12
rules in a modern sense.
He wasn't handing down
the Ten Commandments again
but he was saying in a modern sense
these are 12 things you can do.
Stand up straight with your shoulder back,
with your shoulders back, clean your room,
clean your room before
you clean the world.
These are basic things
where now we have people
that want to fix the world constantly
that can't fix themselves.
They're doing it backwards.
But just very briefly on the underpinning
of some sort of belief
that can lead to freedom
and that's what sort of what
I was talking about
about the Enlightenment.
Think about, you know,
the founding documents of this country
I think are the greatest
man written documents,
let's say, political documents at least.
And what did the Founders say?
They said these are God-given
rights, they're self-evident.
We did not give you these rights,
the right of freedom and
of free speech all things.
We can protect these things
but we didn't give them to you
because they came from somewhere else.
That is so deeply important
and in many ways very unique to America
and that's why there's
such a bizarre assault
on freedom of speech right now
and actually almost everything
in the Bill of Rights
and it comes mostly
from the secular world.
That is a really sad twist
that truly I would not have
expected a couple years ago
even as someone that saw this coming.
I mean five years ago I
was waving me the flag,
going guys there's something
happening here on the Left,
this progressive thing, this no good.
But even, it's gotten so crazy,
that I'm still a little surprised myself.
- To some extent it's almost as though
that the meaning crisis has
almost created this vacuum
and people are finding all
kinds of crazy things to do.
- Oh yeah, they're looking
anywhere you can look,
you can play video games all day,
you can do whatever it
is to fill up that hole
if it's an existential hole
or a hole in belief or whatever it is.
But there's a lot of
ways to fill that hole.
I think Jordan, Jordan in my
opinion has given the best set
of beliefs that take from
a religious tradition
and blend what I would say
our enlightenment values
or basically secular values,
Judeo-Christian values
and he's blended them in
the most effective way.
- I mean, as we're on the subject,
talking about Jordan Peterson,
I know that you're somewhat familiar
with some of what he's
been doing as well, John.
What's your take on what
he's put his finger on,
that obviously so many
people are responding to,
and, yeah, well how does
it relate in your view
to the Christian faith that you hold.
- I think people are longing for sense.
And you mentioned connectedness.
That has almost replaced meaning
but it's not real connectedness.
And I was reading a book
on artificial intelligence just recently
and it was a warning
that people will die
if they're not connected to the internet
because all the meaning
is being placed there.
I mean, think what
Jordan Peterson is doing
is putting a nuclear bomb
in the middle of that
and saying this not good enough.
You've got to get outside of that.
And you're right it is rewiring brains.
The psychologists tell us it's
messing people's brains up,
especially if they try and
use two machines at once.
And therefore I just think
that there's an underlying,
and from where I sit,
people are looking for this
because although they
often don't believe it
or even have never heard of it,
they are made in the image of God.
They're beings who've got
eternity in their hearts.
And a kind of materialist universe
without meaning just won't satisfy them
because they're actually
made for something bigger.
And CS Lewis put it years ago,
"If you find a lie in you that's
not satisfied in this world
"maybe there is another world
"in which it could be satisfied."
And I'm gonna play that
to the world of ideas.
So I really think he's hit a nerve.
- And interestingly if you read his book,
"12 Rules For Life,"
and he's done a number
of lectures.
- Yes, I have.
- Is he's drawing a
great deal on the Bible
especially the Old Testament.
- Oh, sure, he is,
And it has intrigued me
that he has concentrated his lectures
of the Bible on the Old Testament.
Now that to me resonates completely
because I, as a Christian,
have been for years trying
to communicate to people
that they've got to begin
to take the Jewish Scriptures seriously
because there you've got the foundation,
the foundation story
and people are looking for
a story that's big enough
to fit their lives into
and there's the start
of the big story, creation,
human beings made in the image of God
and what that means for their dignity
and their freedom and everything else.
If we just get that one fact.
I remember in Siberia where
I used to go quite a bit
and I gave the first lecture
in 75 years on these issues
in the University of Novosibirsk.
And I made the point, I said,
"Just think of the one statement.
"Human beings made in the image of God."
And I said, "If I believed
that they wouldn't murder one
"of you let alone the 100
million that Stalin did."
And it absolutely erupted the place.
Of course they'd never heard it before.
It was totally new to them.
And I think our society
needs to hear these truths.
And Jordan Peterson is
moving into that area
because he's actually
going back to the book
and not being ashamed of it.
And more power to him, I say.
- Yeah, and just very briefly,
just from being on tour with Jordan,
I told you this backstage
but I never saw the guy
break one of the 12 rules.
I mean try to imagine
how chaotic his life was
in the course of this,
becoming a massive star,
traveling all over the
world, the book sales,
the celebrity, the entire thing,
and he never broke one of those 12 rules.
Just 20 seconds we were at a dinner party
at Douglas Murray's house
with Maajid Nawaz and Jordan,
you may know those guys.
And one of the rules is
that if you see a pet,
if you see a cat in the
street you should pet it.
And Douglas had a cat and we're there
for about three or four
hours, we're having dinner,
we're having a great time
and I'm looking at the cat the whole time
and I'm looking at Jordan.
And I'm going the guy hasn't
pet the cat, like you know,
what am I on tour with this guy for?
Like, is the whole thing
is it, is he a fraud,
what's going on here?
I swear to God I was
thinking it the entire time
and then as we were walking out the door,
Jordan literally and you can
sort of picture Jordan's,
he's very tall and he has
long limbs and he's slender
and he basically sat down in
the cat's bed with the cat
and stroked the cat for
a good five minutes.
And I thought all right
he's the real deal.
(audience laughing)
- We should probably talk about someone
other than Jordan Peterson tonight.
I mean I'd love to key in a
little bit more on your story
Dave--
- Sure.
- Because it sounds like you have been
on something of a journey of discovery
over the last year or two
and obviously very much influenced
by the way Jordan has brought that alive
in his lectures and so on.
So I mean you obviously now
are seeing more and more
the value of religion.
What does that caused you personally to do
in terms of maybe, is it causing you
to rediscover your own
Jewish roots a bit more
and the religious aspect of that?
- Well, I would say
there's two things here
as I said at the beginning.
There's sort of just the cultural affinity
and the understanding of
the history of the people
that came before me which
you know unfortunately
in the case of the Jews is a pretty brutal
often almost unimaginably
horrific history.
And I grew up around Holocaust
survivors and I know that.
That, though the pain of your ancestors
or whatever the history of your
people is can't be the thing
that defines you going forward.
I would say as I've sat down
with believers and non-believers alike,
I've genuinely found,
well I guess sort of this would get
to what you were saying, John.
I have generally found the believers
not only more welcoming so
like in a situation like this
but more open, actually
happier, less dependent on
things outside of themselves,
more self-reliant, let's say.
So I don't think that means
I'm going to be religious per se tomorrow.
That being said, as I said,
I went to this Yom Kippur
service that Dennis Prager hosted
and I found it incredibly moving.
And Dennis gave a sermon that, you know,
he talked all about Judeo-Christian values
and sort of what's happening
in our country right now
and how it all seems to
be becoming untethered
and he used some religious
backing to give some value there.
And I thought well this is value,
this something in a real world way
that I could come somewhere once a week
or build some community around or friends
that would have value.
So I can't say I'm, you
know it's like if ultimately
I can see in your eye
you want me to be like,
yeah, yeah, Jesus let it go.
(audience laughing)
I can see it.
There's a guy back there
waving a Jesus sign at me.
All right, I see you.
(audience laughing)
- [Justin] Well, if you insist.
- Yeah, let's put it this way.
I have no problem with
Jesus, I like the guy.
You know what I mean?
Like the message of Jesus
that all of the things
that we've talked about
here on stage and backstage,
I love these ideas.
I think that if my life becomes
a continuing conversation
about these things
and I can incorporate
the best parts of that
to be a better person?
Well, I'll tell you this.
I know for a fact, I am
a better person today
than I was before I started
this journey with Jordan.
That those things, and that
doesn't mean I prescribe
to the Church of Jordan Peterson,
that is just that this guy
who has communicated the bedrock ideas
that we're talking about here,
by me listening to that and hearing that
and incorporating some of that in my life,
I'm a better person.
So that means something,
you know what I mean?
- Any comments on Dave's journey so far?
- Feel like "This is My life."
(audience laughing)
- You're on--
- all right.
- [Justin] The
psychiatrists couch tonight.
- Well I think what
struck me, just listening,
was you're being moved by Yom Kippur.
I'm not Jewish by background
but I owe everything to a Jew
and the history of the Jews has been
enormously important to me.
And when you mention
the Holocaust as you do
and I've been in Auschwitz many times.
And I've wept every time.
And I have many Jewish
friends who lost everybody
and that raises huge, deep,
existential questions.
And therefore just thinking
of the big picture,
the big biblical story and I love it
because although there are all sorts
of twists and turns and difficulties,
I see the Jewish history,
the history of Israel,
the law, the prophets as
pointing towards something big
because at the heart of Judaism
and I have many Orthodox friends
who still expect Hamashiach,
the Messiah, to come.
Now the difference is that
I believe he has come.
And Yom Kippur means a huge amount to me
because in those Jewish festivals,
and I've been at many of them,
I see, I don't want to put a crudely
but a thought model
that has been fulfilled
in what Jesus did.
And I find Yom Kippur moving
because I see in him the fulfillment of it
and here is a person who actually
died the Day of Atonement.
It's an atonement to deal with.
Now here comes the point.
That what happens when you start
with a creation story of people made
in the image of God, that's wonderful.
But we know that something has happened,
a bomb has hit the human race.
There are huge problems
and we long for a solution.
We long for justice.
We long for true freedom.
We long for true values.
And we've got to
therefore face the problem
of human rebellion against God.
Now the sin word is
not popular these days.
But it seems to me that
there's a fulfillment
within what Jesus did and taught,
a fulfillment that everything
that Judaism stood for
and stands for powerfully.
And therefore I feel
a close affinity here,
the whole Judeo tradition
is immensely important to me
because there I find
these fundamental values.
But they raise a big question
and it's the fulfillment of that,
the whole history of
Israel, its sacrifices,
the institutions, the prophets
looking forward to Messiah
who will deal with the basic
problem of human rebellion.
And so that's clearly a
difference between me and Judaism.
But I wouldn't underemphasize
the huge contribution
that it has made to the rock
on which I believe I stand
today, if that makes sense.
- Well it does make sense
and if I could quickly,
I actually do want to answer
your question a little more specifically
now that I had a moment
to think it through.
So this year I went, my
parents live in New York still,
in the same family home that I grew up in.
And I went to a temple on Rosh Hashanah
and Rosh Hashanah is the
beginning of the new year
and it's about creation.
And then basically you have the week or so
between Rosh Hashanah and Yom Kippur
where you're supposed to
think about your life,
the things that you've done,
the good things that you've done,
the bad things you've
done, apologize to people
if you've done, whoever
you may have done harm.
And I really did, so
this is the real answer
to your question, I
really did that this year.
I really did think about it.
Probably didn't fully get there on Twitter
throughout the week.
I probably did drop the ball
a couple times on Twitter.
But I really was very aware of that
and I tried, you know, just
a few days ago at services,
I really was trying to be cognizant of
it doesn't necessarily matter if I believe
in all of this, all of it fully.
But there is value in this,
this story that has
been told by my parents
and my grandparents and
my great-grandparents
going way back when.
There must have been something
that kept this thing alive
and there must have been
some reason behind it.
And for me to pretend
that I'm so enlightened
that I have figured out
something that is so brilliant
that I could just set all that aside
that it, to me that strikes
me is the worst sort
of like egomaniacal hubris
that you could have.
So I would be happy to
do this again next year
and we can continue the conversation.
The Jesus guy's still
waving at me back there.
(audience laughing)
- Good.
I'm finding this fascinating
because obviously there has been something
of a spiritual awakening.
And I think, yeah it
sounds like you're saying,
I'm not quite sure what
that looks like exactly
but I want to start to investigate
and live into this kind of tradition more
that obviously your
forebears have done so.
I mean there's a lot of people out there
who would say, "Come on, wake
up, it's the 21st century.
"We all know that these
are just superstitions
"and everything else and you need to get
"on the bandwagon of reason."
You're about reason, Dave.
And if we just think straight,
work things out with science and logic
then that's the way
forward, that's the way you,
religion is kind of the way
we used to do things not anymore.
- Yeah, well I think the
counter to that would be
that everything that
Jordan has talked about,
not to bring this back to Jordan,
but the counter of that
is that we'll look sort of
where the secular world is
at where we can't figure out
whether you're male or female anymore
we have to now debate that.
I don't it's sort of like
I don't like using that one
because it's so easy and
it sounds sort of glib
and I don't mean it to be that way.
But that is where this all leading.
If there is nothing outside
of ourselves then, John,
as you said everything else is subjective
and we will debate every little thing
depending on how we feel
about it on any given day.
And that will lead,
there is there's a reason
why right now the idea of
socialism is suddenly popping up
in America which is the
genuinely the worst set
of collectivist ideas that
you could possibly ever have
that hundreds of millions
of people have died in history under.
And it's popping up because if you listen
to what's happening on the
Left right now politically
because they've outsourced God,
imagine if one of those
people on stage said
that they were a real believer.
Imagine if any of them,
maybe Biden could do it,
but really the rest of them can't.
They would never really say
that they're a believer.
Now I don't know what they are
and I wouldn't want them to say anything
that's not true to themselves
But they would be mocked
by everything mainstream,
everything mainstream
would mock them the way
that everything mainstream
mocks any Christian
that happens, 'cause they're
usually on the Right,
they happen to be conservatives.
But look what they're offering us now.
Their answer is, okay we've
removed God from the equation
and what do we get, we get government.
And they now pray basically to government.
They think that they
can figure out somehow
by sitting in a room with a
bunch of other politicians
and bureaucrats, the worst
sort of people that exist,
(audience laughing)
I didn't even mean that
to be funny but actually.
I mean, but that's what they think.
They think that they can
rejigger all of humanity
in a way that will be so much better
than everything that came before them.
And not only can't they,
they are going to do the complete reverse.
So that, if for no other reason,
if for no grand revelation
or something like that,
that would be a reason to be respectful
of people that are believers
because they can fight that in
a way that secularists can't.
The good liberals don't have enough juice
in and of themselves,
they don't have enough
juice to fight that.
That's why liberalism has collapsed
in the name of progressivism.
- Yeah, I approach this in two ways.
The first one is your comment
that secularism is collapsing.
And one can analyze the defects of atheism
where it leads to and
the millions of people
that died in the last century.
But coming over to the other side.
What you're saying, Justin,
you see I am a scientist
and one of the fascinating things is
that science is a direct legacy
of the Judeo-Christian tradition.
You were saying we're all
scientists now and all this is,
no, it is not.
And let's start absolutely basic.
In the beginning God created
the heavens and the earth.
Hebrew Bible written millennia ago
knew there was a beginning.
It was in the early '60s
before scientists caught up with that.
(audience laughing)
And the Bible was right.
And Dawkins said, "Well
there was a 50/50 chance,"
when I debated him.
And I said, "At least
the Bible got it right."
But more seriously than that, you see,
the fact that I'm a mathematician
and interested in science,
all right, just think about that.
The fact that mathematics
can describe what goes on
in the universe is a
matter of huge wonder.
Einstein once said, "The
only incomprehensible thing
"about the universe is
that it's comprehensible."
And he saw the problem.
Why does it work?
Well it's not an incomprehensible thing
if you start from the idea
that there's an intelligent God
who made us in His image and
therefore we can do science.
And that's exactly what the early pioneers
of modern science, starting with Galileo
and Kepler and Newton
and so on and so forth.
They were all believers in God.
And therefore when I hear
that kind of question
I'm not remotely ashamed
of being a scientist
and a Christian because I want to argue
that it was Christianity
gave me my subject.
And CS Lewis put it brilliantly.
(audience applauding)
(audience laughing)
I'm glad you understood it in the end.
CS Lewis said, "Men became scientific
"because they expected law in nature.
"And they expected law nature
"because they believed in a lawgiver."
And I think we're getting to the stage now
where serious atheist
thinkers are beginning
to reexamine the kind of naturalism
that reduces everything
to physics and chemistry.
And one of them lives in New
York, his name is Thomas Nagel
and he's a brilliant philosopher.
And he says something's going wrong
because if everything is
reducible to physics and chemistry
then so is your mind but then
why would you trust your mind?
In other words atheism taken
to its logical conclusion
undermines the very rationality you need
to trust to do science.
And I'm not in for accepting a worldview
that undermines the foundations
of any kind of argument
or discussion whatsoever.
So I think that in the 21st century
we can push back on that very naive notion
that God's out, we do science now.
No, science actually brings God back in.
- It's very interesting, I mean.
(audience applauding)
All of this leads me to want
to ask you at this point, Dave,
you're sitting down
with John here tonight,
obviously a Christian believer,
someone who gives evidences for God.
And I know that on your show
you've had people like Bishop Barron
and I think Ravi Zacharias
is gonna be featured shortly.
Where does this leave you on
if you like that God question?
Because one level, I can
absolutely see the way
in which there's a kind of the utility
and a kind of sense in which meaning,
we can gather meaning from
doing the religious things,
the rituals and so on.
But at the end of the day
and I asked this of Jordan Peterson once,
it was an interesting answer.
Do you believe in God?
Do you feel like that's
where you've got to
at this point in your life?
- You know it's funny
when we would do the Q&As
at the shows with Jordan
for the first few we
would let people come up
to the microphone.
And what usually happens is
that people start telling
their life story and they would want
to get a therapy session in
front of 3,000 strangers.
And it started getting very weird
so we decided to better rate it.
We used an app to do it and
when Jordan was on stage,
basically, I would go
through the best ones
and I'd find some funny
ones and some serious ones
and everything else.
But what always came up,
no matter how many times
Jordan answered it was,
do you believe in God?
And he and as I'm sure he
said to you, he finds it to be
sort of the most annoying
question possible.
So I think I would answer it,
I mean I would answer it in a
similar way that Jordan would.
That look I think I've sort of laid out
a set of beliefs here
that show the utility
of believing in something
outside of myself
and I do believe in that.
So if you want to call that God,
that there is something outside of me,
there is something that
is connecting all of us
that has nothing to do
with the material world,
there is something that drives us
that is the driver of humanity,
that is something good, I believe that.
I don't, I can't, yeah I believe that.
(audience applauding)
- But could you put a name on
that something at this point?
(audience laughing)
I told you I wanted to label
you by the end of the evening.
- Ah, Jesus?
(audience laughing)
(audience cheering)
- I guess, I mean in a sense
I hear what you're saying.
- Do I get a cookie at least?
I mean, come on people
what are you doing here?
(audience laughing)
- I guess it's kind of like
what are the particulars though?
What would that look, how is
that gonna make a difference,
I suppose in your life,
is there a sort of sense
in which you feel now
any new obligations given
this kind of new sense
that there is something beyond yourself.
- You know, I think we're all
sort of wired differently, right?
I think some people can
really, can really flourish
just sort of on their own set of ideas
that they create in the world.
And I think that can really
work for some people.
I think some people need
some order outside of that.
Some people need more of a community,
some people are real loners.
All of those things.
I think perhaps, but I truly
mean what I said before,
I'd be happy to do this
every year with you
and continue these conversations
and I'll continue them
on my show obviously.
I think for me the
adventure of discussing this
and seeing what kind of people
that I bring into my studio
that interact with at events like this,
what type of people I want to be around,
that really is the proof.
That is what,
well that's what makes this, right?
That's what makes this.
So I don't know, so again
I can't what you're,
I get the question, I
respect the question truly
and it's the question, right?
I mean it's like saying,
what's the meaning of life?
Right, it's the big one.
I would say I'm on the
adventure to finding that out
and I'm really okay with that.
I hope that doesn't sound dismissive
of the question or like
I'm trying to evade it.
I'm really not.
I like, and maybe this just a function
also of what I do for a living.
I mean I get to sit every week with people
that in most cases are smarter than me,
who have spent years working
through all of these issues
as you have, John.
And that is an incredible
privilege that I have.
So I would like to see
how far I can take that.
- Sounds like we're not
gonna convert him tonight.
(audience laughing)
- You're doing your best.
- Yeah, working overtime over
there, I'll tell ya that much.
- But it's wonderful
to hear an open description of a journey.
And I try to think my way into this
that getting around these
ideas is really big stuff.
I mean coming the way you've moved
from the little I've understood of it
just meeting you for the first time
it's most interesting to me the way
that movement is going.
Now from where I sit there's
another element comes into it.
What I mean by that is this.
There's the things that we
can think about existentially
as you're doing and that's
vastly important to me as well.
The kind of people you like to be with,
the evidence of that, you like this,
if you feel there's
something outside yourself
and so on and so forth.
But then it comes to
a couple of questions,
One is, could it be that
something is actually personal?
Now you're Jewish Hebrew
Scriptures would say exactly so
because that's how
Bereshit, Genesis, starts
with a God who sees,
who blesses, who speaks.
And one of the most
interesting things to me,
both as a scientist and a believer in God,
is the simple description of creation.
And God said, "Let there be light."
And God said and God said.
There's a sequence as you know.
But the most exciting one
is the one you never hear.
It's the final one and God said to them.
And that opens up a whole
world of possibility.
That what is being
claimed at least is that
there's a God that speaks to me
and that means that opens up
the possibility of revelation
where it's not simply me
investigating the people I know,
the things I hear, the arguments
philosophically and so on.
But there's another side to it.
That if this is true then
God is interested in me
and he's wanting me as
a discussion partner.
He's wanting to talk to me.
And if one is open to that possibility
it seems to me to open a
huge new dimension to this.
And the more I think about that,
this a word based universe scientifically
and religiously in that sense.
And therefore the idea
that there's something
there, that's fantastic.
There's more than the material world.
But if that more is
personal and can speak to us
it's worth testing the claim at least
because it runs right through the whole
of the Hebrew Scriptures
and the New Testament.
That's the fundamental thing
is a speaking God, not dead.
(audience applauding)
- I should say, I mean we normally never
on my show get to this point
because most of the
time the person sitting
opposite someone like John
is a confirmed atheist.
And it's really, God is
always gonna be debated
in the abstract.
John you kind of come to
the point we're saying,
well let's look at where
the God could be personal.
- Yes.
- Whether God could speak to us.
Again I feel like we're
grilling you tonight
but I guess--
- No, it's fine, it's interesting.
I genuinely I love this there's
nothing you could ask me
I don't think that would
that would offend me or--
- Well, I really I'm grateful
for you being an open book tonight
because I suppose my
next is question simply,
could it be?
Do you think that it's possible
that there could be a God
who is personally interested in you,
who listens to your prayers,
who is interested in the
way you live your life,
who wants the best for you?
Is that something that's on
the table as a possibility
for where your journey
might take you, I suppose.
- If he walks out on stage right now,
I would get baptized tomorrow, okay.
(audience laughing)
Like if this is like a Maury Povich
and here he is everybody!
(audience laughing)
Yes, well my basic answer would be, yes.
Why would I rule that out?
Why, as you said that so eloquently,
would I be like, no.
That just doesn't stand to reason.
And that again goes back to why I said
I love having these conversations.
And I don't even, though
this a little different
for what you do usually,
I don't take offense by it
or anything like that.
Like that's interesting to me.
But and by the way I think
that this sort of where Jews
maybe have done something
a little bit differently,
where it always has been
about this sort of battle
about what God is?
You talk about science and mathematics.
You can go to most of the Jewish hospitals
in New York City where
they have the best doctors
in the entire world, many
of them are Orthodox Jews
who actually won't press
the elevator on Shabbat
because they don't want to
use electricity on Shabbat.
So they have the elevators
that go to every floor on Saturdays.
Now from an outsider perspective
you weren't really
thinking about it that way,
you'd go well that's completely crazy.
How are these people of
science and math, doctors,
why would they possibly care
in this crazy superstition
if you come from that
discipline of science and math.
And yet those people don't
find it to be in conflict.
So I don't see any of
this in conflict actually.
If anything, I feel like
this really what it's about.
This ability to play, because
I know that there are plenty
of you guys out there
that are at some level
of where I'm at with some of this stuff.
It's not like everyone that
walks in these doors is going
this absolutely what I believe
and we believe the same thing
and I want to convert everybody
to believe in the same thing I do.
I just, I don't believe that.
I'm not gonna poll you don't worry.
(audience laughing)
But I know that's true.
And we're all on those journeys together.
So of course I don't dismiss
could God be a personal,
you know do we all have
that piece of us behind us
that knows what's right when
you make a bad choice in life.
You have those, yeah, I
shouldn't have that drink
or shouldn't do this or whatever it is.
I don't know is that a
personal relationship with God
when you have that other thing
or some would say is that
just the voice in your head,
what is that, what is that thing?
I mean philosophers have
been debating this forever.
- I think that's a really great place
just to draw this part of
the conversation to a close.
- Thank God.
(audience laughing)
Whoa, all right, okay.
Literally, I mean that.
- Let's give a round of
applause to John and Dave.
(audience applauding)
(audience cheering)
(upbeat music)
(audience applauding)
Oh there's a lot for you I'm afraid, Dave.
(audience laughing)
- Can I text in a couple
questions myself right now?
- I mean there is one very obvious one
which someone wants to
ask and if you could
this could be a whole
evening for you, John,
but someone simply asks
what for you would be
the key evidences for God
if you were in a conversation
with someone about that?
- It depends entirely whom I'm talking to
because it seems to me there
are two kinds of evidence.
There's the objective kind of evidence.
That is from the scientific point of view,
looking at the universe, the beginning,
the fine-tuning of the universe
and all those pointers,
the very doing of science that point
to an intelligence behind the universe.
That would be one set.
The second set would be the
whole revelation through Christ
and who he is and what he did
and all that kind of thing.
And central to it of
course would be the fact
that I believe the death
problem has been solved
in the sense that at the
heart of Christianity
there's not only a
death but a resurrection
which validates the
significance of the death.
So I want to go into the what
I believe are the evidences
for the resurrection
historically and so on.
And then finally there's
the existential side.
Many people say to me
you can't be a Christian
and a scientist because
Christianity is not testable.
And I say of course it's testable.
And to be blunt about that, very briefly,
Christ makes certain
claims that if we trust him
he'll give us peace with God, forgiveness,
new life, a new par.
You can test that.
And you know in my life,
which has been quite long,
I've met many people and you meet them
and there maybe in the midst
of a broken relationship,
narcotic dependence,
all kinds of stuff and you
meet them six months later
and they're completely different.
And you say, "What's happened to you?"
Now they may express
it in different terms.
They may say, "Well I became a Christian,"
or "I was born again,"
or "I was converted."
But when you see that as I
have done again and again
not only in my own life
and those around me
but in people around you,
you add two and two and you get four.
And I wouldn't sit here for
a nanosecond as a Christian
if I didn't believe it can
be tested in real experience.
If it doesn't work then it's very suspect.
So that is the fastest
answer I can give to that.
- Thank you very much
ready for the answers.
(audience applauding)
That's a lot of thinking boiled down
into a very brief answer.
Question for you, Dave, has come in
and it's what do you find
unbelievable about Christianity?
So I guess the question is,
okay you're on a journey,
you're willing to be open
to that potential answer
what are the main objections at this point
that you would have to kind of embracing
that kind of a view?
- Well I suppose it's a good question
because I don't have a
particularly good answer for it.
So I think we could probably
do this one pretty quickly.
I mean, I don't, there's no...
Well other than what
would be a generic answer
about any religion.
Let's say some sort of
like true leap of faith
to ultimately say this
whether it's Christianity
or Judaism or whatever you want to say,
whatever religion or set of
ideas we're talking about.
Beyond that full jump I don't have any,
there's nothing, there's
nothing that's been said up here
there's nothing that John has talked about
or than any of the religious thinkers
that I've had on recently.
The conversation that I
had with Ravi Zacharias,
it's going up next week
I think is one of the best interviews
that I've ever been part of.
There was nothing that he said there
in the course of that hour and a half
that I found objectionable
or I found completely incongruent
with my set of beliefs, let's say.
So I don't know that I have,
there's no answer for
that in that I'm willing
to keep continue that conversation.
- A few people have asked a
follow-up question effectively
which is I mean do, it's
phrased in a few different ways,
so I'll try and--
- Is it hot here?
(audience laughing)
- It kind of goes to the
heart of Christianity though
which is what do you think
about the central claim
that Jesus rose from the dead.
Because that at the end of the day is
at the heart of the faith John holds.
Is that something you would
be open to investigating
to kind of you know seeing
whether there's anything in that claim?
- Yeah I, look, I think I don't know
how many of these types of
questions there's going to be.
- [Justin] I won't do
too many more of them.
- But yes I can't,
I wish I could think of
a better way to say it.
But I am completely open
to these discussions
as they have, your answer
actually John was perfect.
That if these things weren't testable
in that you did not see the evidence
that people were living better
lives, more fulfilled lives,
happier lives, all those things,
that you wouldn't as a man of science,
you could not sit up here.
That's a really beautiful answer
that feels to me to be
complete as a person of faith
and a person of science, right?
And I think that would be a worldview
that I could prescribe to
and that is that actually is a worldview
that I prescribe to.
And that doesn't exclude
the fact that very early on
I said that at the micro level
some of my best friends are atheists
and they are deeply
moral, good, decent people
and you've debated many of them.
so there's no, there's nothing
that is so separate, let's say.
- I mean, I promise no more
grilling you on faith questions.
But for John, kind of the
opposite question coming in.
Is there, have you ever
questioned if there is a God?
And another person asks, whether
you've ever been presented
with an objection that
you found difficult?
- Oh, can I do that one?
(audience laughing)
Come on, man.
- Of course I have.
You see, this interest me
because I spent my whole life
not only questioning
myself but exposing myself
to some of the most powerful
questioners in the world
who are against my viewpoint.
And the reason for doing that
is partially the Freudian one.
The accusation that was made
against me at Cambridge.
You believe because your parents believe
and your grandparents believe
and it's Irish genetics, end of story.
(audience laughing)
So I have questioned
everything in that sense
and it's through that my certainty comes.
You see, the word faith
has flicked in there
to this conversation and
we need to be careful
what we mean by that.
By faith I don't mean
a leap into the dark.
I mean a step into the
light that's evidence-based
and it's exactly the same
kind of commitment in science.
We believe certain
things about the universe
because we've evidence.
Now in Christianity it
is exactly parallel.
Real faith is a commitment,
a step based on evidence
and of course there's a personal
dimension to Christianity
that doesn't occur
when you're believing Einstein's
equations for example.
It's not quite the same
as trusting a person.
But still it's got to be
evidence-based or else is blind.
And blind faith is extremely dangerous,
particularly in the sphere of religion.
So asking questions all
the time is a process
that I discover in the Bible itself
which is one of the things
that makes it credible.
Jesus was always asking questions
and he didn't always answer them
and his disciples were asking questions.
My great intellectual hero was Socrates
who was forced to commit suicide
because he corrupted the youth of Athens
which meant that he taught
kids to ask questions
their parents couldn't answer.
Which is usually what kids do.
But it seems to me that
it's very important.
My whole process of relating
to people, as Dave's is,
is asking them questions
and getting them to open themselves.
So yes, absolutely this
is the way the thing works
and that is where assurance comes.
It's fear that stops us
questioning the propositions
or the commitments of what we believe.
And I want to break
through that fear barrier
and get into a proper public discourse.
- There's a question here which
relates to a story you told
on your podcast of being
I think at a John Peterson lecture night
and you met a couple
who had both been
through a difficult time.
Perhaps you can tell the story.
I think a miscarriage is involved
and there were difficulties in the family
and the way you responded
was the interesting
perhaps part of that story as well.
Do you want to tell the story
and just maybe dig into that a bit
because the person asks
that they'd just like
to hear a little bit more about that.
- Yeah, you know it's so interesting
that someone's asking this
because I actually don't remember telling
this story publicly.
But I must have said it
publicly at some point.
I don't remember.
We were in the UK, I don't
remember what city we were in,
but a couple came up to me before the show
and they both looked very,
they were just sort of distraught.
You know sometimes you
people come up to you
and you could just see it in their face,
you could feel in their body language
and they started talking to me.
And basically it turned out
that he, oh, it was young couple
I mean they were in their
maybe late 20s, early 30s
and the guy had just found out
that he had like stage four cancer
and didn't have much time to live.
And then, yeah, I mean
that you can't believe
it is actually real.
The woman found out that she was pregnant,
she was a few months pregnant
and the fetus had died
and she was gonna have to have it removed
like the next day or something like that.
I mean like unimaginably
horrific circumstances.
And they said this to me and then said
that Jordan's helped
them get a little meaning
over the last few weeks as
they've been going to doctors
and all of these things.
And I think the reason that
the person's mentioning
that I bring it up is the only thing
that I could say was, "God
bless you, God bless you, guys."
That's what I said.
I had, there was nothing else,
there was just nothing else I could say.
What can I possibly say,
"I'm sorry to hear about
what you're going through."
You know, I hugged them I tried
to just kind of stand there
and be with them.
But that happened to be
what popped up in my brain.
So if that, in a weird way,
if that is evidence of something,
if that is that when
faced with unimaginable,
I mean no one can possibly
imagine the level of horror
of that situation.
I hope I'm getting it
fully technically right.
That's what I had left I would say.
- It was the only words
that you felt made sense.
- Can I make a comment?
- Yes, please do.
- Because I didn't answer your question.
And one of your questions to me was
do you make objections that
you find difficult to answer.
And I do and that's one.
The problem of moral evil and pain,
which is what you talked about,
is the hardest question
that any of us face.
And it has been a very
important part of my life
to try and think that through.
I arrived in Christchurch,
New Zealand two days
after the earthquake and I
had to cancel all my talks
and replace them with "Earthquake, Why?"
Now that's not easy to deal with.
Now, the atheists say, "Well
it's just the way the world is.
"There is no God, that's
just what you'd expect."
But you see, if you abolish God
and I'm not gonna go into details in this
but it's hugely important.
If you abolish God actually
you can make the problem worse
because there's now no hope.
If you bring God into the equation
from the Christian perspective
there is the hope of the Resurrection.
And not going into it in detail,
I want to say two big
things to this problem.
They're not answers, that would
be simplistic and trivial.
But they're are a window
into a possibility.
And the window into the
possibility is this.
If it really is true that's
God incarnate on the cross
what does it mean?
Well at the very least it means
that God has not remained
distant from human suffering.
He has become part of it.
And so your God bless you,
I think it's a huge layers
of meaning underlying it.
That's the first thing.
And the fact that Jesus
rose from the dead means
that ultimately there is real hope.
Why, because one of the things
the early Christians preached was
that the resurrection
guaranteed a final judgment.
And we don't like that
idea, but think about it.
If there's going to be an
utterly fair assessment,
although as I said I've been
to Auschwitz many times,
if there's going to be a judgment
that deals with these things
that gives me a window of hope.
And so, therefore, I think
this the hardest problem
for anybody and any philosophy
in any world for you nobody escapes it.
- A question for you this time, John.
And maybe you might want
comment on it as well, Dave.
But someone asked what
does it take for a person
to move from an abstract
intellectual belief in God
to this personal experiential
faith which you talked about.
- Well that's assuming that they start
with an abstract faith.
Now people come different ways.
Our journeys, and that's why
it's so interesting talking about journey
and I haven't finished my journey yet.
There are lots of questions
I've got, things unresolved.
I started by the existential
side, the personal side,
I saw it was real.
But then as a child I was
taught to ask the questions,
so the intellectual side
and the practical side walked hand in hand
throughout my life.
And some people come to faith in Christ
because they've been
befriended by somebody
that shows a real friendship
and it's existential.
Others come because they've
been challenged intellectually.
I was speaking in Germany a week ago
and speaking with a
very intellectual person
and what started him off in
his journey was at school
he was grown up in a, he grew up in a home
where all his father said about everything
was everything's lies, that
was his, everything's lies.
Total skepticism.
And he had a school
friend, they sat together
and the school friend said to him one day,
he said, "Jesus Christ
rose from the dead."
And this chap thought, "What?"
And he started to investigate it.
And that led him to become
an ancient historian.
And now in Germany he'll fill a hall
with 5,000 people talking about
how he became a Christian from skepticism.
So the intellectual side got him first.
So you can't generalize at all.
But I think in that sense
if a person is just cerebral about it
they haven't understood it
because Christ does make demands.
There's a relational thing,
there are moral dimensions to it.
And so it needs to move,
how shall I put it?
I'm worried about the distinction
because even when we're
emotional about something
the emotions are
precipitated by our thoughts.
You can't separate thought and emotion.
But I think the important
thing is that since,
let me put it this way.
God is not simply a philosophical theory.
He's a person and therefore our response
to persons is different from a response
to say a mathematical equation.
And we need to take the various dimensions
and aspects into account.
So I'd simply want to
encourage a person like that
to think about, well, what
does Christianity mean
that you should be doing.
But since it's an abstract question,
I don't know the person,
everybody's different.
- I'm tossing it over to you, Dave.
There's a sense in which, you know,
we've talked a lot about
Jordan Peterson this evening.
But when I see him on stage,
he's not afraid of getting emotional.
In fact, he quite frequently
is close to tears very often
when it's talking about
the search for meaning,
when he's engaging with
where people are at
in their struggles and so on.
And in that sense he's quite the antidote
to the kind of very coldly
rational kind of approach
that many sort of big thinkers
often take to these issues.
Is that something that's attracted you,
I don't know, to the
way in which he engages
with that kind of aspect of
reality in a very personal way
in a sense in which he
approaches these kinds of issues?
- Yeah, well I can answer that two ways.
First, not specifically with Jordan,
but I think one of the
reasons that the YouTube game
and the podcast game and
all of the digital stuff
and all of this new set of personalities
that you guys all watch
and consume and listen to,
the reason it's working is
because these people are being people.
These are actual people.
I mean the person that you see
when I'm doing something on YouTube,
that's this guy that's right
in front of you right now.
I happen to be on stage with a mic
but I'm the same person
when I step down there
and talk to you guys.
Jordan is the same person.
As I said, he lived those 12 rules.
He's the same exact guy, right?
There's a little something
when there's a camera there
I forget what the sight,
there's a theory, you know,
that you all, when a camera's on
you turn it on like 5% or something.
But I think what's happened
over the last 20 or so years
with cable news is that
everyone on television became
so incredibly fake and over prepared
and really ridiculously robotic
that there is a breath of fresh air
when people just actually are decent,
when people just actually can
look each other in the eye
and not pretend that they have
every answer to every question.
I think that's a deeply powerful thing.
So when Jordan would go
onstage and he, I kid you not,
it's almost unimaginable but
the guy 110 some-odd shows
that we did together, he never
gave the same lecture twice.
He would give a different,
some nights he would
talk about all 12 rules,
some nights he would talk about one rule,
some nights four rules,
some nights he would just
talk about the media,
some nights he would talk about YouTube.
I mean, it was just
whatever was in his mind.
And you know, the book,
he was on a book tour
they wanted him to sell a book.
Sometimes the book never came up.
I mean, he just didn't he,
but to answer your question specifically
he was being present as much as possible.
That is something that I
really try to do in my life
and when you're doing it right
you don't really have to try
because it just starts happening
and you just start being real.
And that's why actually I've thoroughly,
as I just said to you guys at halftime
or whatever we're calling
it the Dave Rubin grilling.
I've really enjoyed this because
this is real, this is real.
And the more that we can do that,
the better we can understand each other.
So there would be nights
where he would be on stage,
you know, telling the story
that I'm sure many of you have heard
where he talks about Pinocchio.
And the reason that you
have to wish upon a star
and what that means and
then he would link it
to a biblical story and he would tear up
and he would cry and
you could hear the crack
in his voice and it was real.
We would be backstage
right after the show,
just sitting in the greenroom
and I would just kind of sit there
and give him his moment
to collect himself.
So it was real.
And I think all that really
is is being vulnerable,
being open, the best way
I could describe it was
what I saw the guy do was that every night
that he went onstage he tried to take
as much of his intellect
and his set of beliefs
he would take them as far as
he could on any given night
and there were nights
where I could see him stretch
that a little bit further.
That's a pretty incredible
thing to be around.
- On a slightly lighter note, someone ask,
Jordan Peterson versus Ben
Shapiro wrestling match,
Who'd win?
(audience laughing)
- Well Jordan's tall and
lanky Ben is quick and short.
So I feel like he'd take
out the legs, you know?
Ben probably, probably, Ben will start,
Ben's you know about, you
know, 20 years younger, so.
- So many of these
questions actually are--
- He could actually use the yarmulke
as some kind of boomerang or something.
There's things, there's
things the guy can do.
- Here's a serious question.
- What am I doing here, exactly?
- This is really, this is a tough one.
I mean, I know I've heard
this you put this position
but as much as you
obviously have a great deal
of respect for people like Ben Shapiro
and other religious figures,
you disagree with them
on some pretty fundamental things,
some ethical issues, for instance.
- Sure.
- So, for instance, Ben
Shapiro's very strongly opposed
to abortion and someone
asks you on text here
what about you, what would it
take to change your position
on that particular ethical issue
knowing that you are pro-choice?
- So I describe myself as
begrudgingly pro-choice
which I take no pleasure in
even discussing abortion.
I find this to be the issue,
beyond any other political issue,
I find this to be the most polarizing
and almost impossible to talk about
because you're talking about
the most existential question there is
which is the beginning of life, right?
And the way that it gets
framed, unfortunately,
through the media is that
if you're on the right
you somehow hate women
and if you're on the left
you somehow hate babies.
And that sort of ridiculous false choice
that we're constantly,
basically playing ping-pong
between is insane.
My position basically is that,
look, I believe in the individual.
Now I get why that could be messy
in a conversation about abortion
because I do believe that
a fetus is life, I do.
And we can, and it's up to
ethicists and philosophers
and all sorts of scientific minded people
and theologians actually, as well,
to decide is that the moment
the sperm meets the egg
or is that two weeks later?
And there's different religious traditions
that can teach you all
sorts of different things.
My belief is that the individual,
we as a society cannot
have a perfect system
that is perfect for everyone all the time.
What we can try to do is
have some set of rules
that can maximize human
flourishing the most it can.
What I believe is basically
that you have a couple week window.
A few years ago and the
first time I debated this
with Ben Shapiro who's
obviously completely pro-life,
so he's completely anti-abortion,
I used to say 20 weeks because
there was scientific evidence
that at 20 weeks the fetus
can actually feel pain.
And what Ben said to me,
which I think is a completely
legitimate argument, he said,
"Well, so you're saying
you're admitting it's a life
"and you're acknowledging,
well, if you're saying 20 weeks,
"well then 18 weeks is
obviously still alive.
"Why not 18 weeks?"
And I granted him that
inconsistency in this view
because I'm not trying to
come up with a perfect system.
I'm trying to come up with some system
that would allow the 350
million people that live
in this country to have some guideline
that we could most, somewhat
agree on, something like that.
The problem right now is
that the 12 Democratic
candidates have gone
so off the deep end with this
that they're talking about,
I mean they're literally talking
about post-birth abortions
like we have heard some
beyond hysterical crazy stuff.
Tulsi Gabbard, who I had on my show,
she said that she would not
want third term abortions
which by any measure, even
if it's not for you guys,
let's say here, because I'm
assuming you're mostly pro-life
that would have been considered
a pretty moderate position
for a Democrat 10 years ago.
But for her now in that field
that is a wildly out there position
because they all believe basically
you can have an abortion, at any time.
I mean this even where Biden,
who's supposed to be the adult
in the group is now kind of, right?
He's supposed, I mean that's why
they dragged him back into this,
he didn't want to do it they're, you know,
but he was supposed to be the adult
and go guys know you're all bananas
and you know settle down.
But it's not working.
So what was your question?
What would get me to change on that or?
- Well I suppose that
that would be a really
interesting thing to ask.
Would this journey that you're going on
of being open to potentially
God and to religious answers
to things cause you to
reconsider your view on that.
- Well, I would say these things
don't have nothing to do
with each other, right?
So if we find, if we find a
speck of something on the moon
that has some resemblance
of life or a cell
or something we say it's life.
So I'm not denying that from conception.
I'm actually not denying that's life.
What I'm trying to do just as someone
that talks about things
in a public way is to,
you're not gonna satisfy
everybody all the time.
And by the way the most
uncomfortable truth about this is
that humans get left with
all sorts of horrific choices
that they don't want to have to deal with.
And if abortion was completely illegal
that actually would not stop abortion.
It would also make it much more dangerous.
There would be access for people
that had certain resources financially,
that other people wouldn't have.
- [Justin] It's very complex, yes, yes.
- There's just a series
of uncomfortable truths
that we would have to
deal with to do that.
But I would say I would say
I'm begrudgingly pro-choice
and trust me this one
more than a God question
because this a sort of policy issue.
I mean up here and now,
I find it to be the most
difficult one to answer.
- [Justin] I mean John,
I'd just interested
in your reflection on this,
not necessarily getting to
the bottom of this issue
which could take us all evening
but to what extent for you
does being a believer in God
and specifically Christianity mean
that your views on that kind of thing have
to take a certain direction in terms
of the views of abortion
and the sanctity of life
and that kind of thing?
- I think the important thing to realize,
and we don't focus it sharply enough,
is that in part ethics
are worldview dependent.
What I mean by that is this.
If you think that a fetus is
just simply at the early stage
an undifferentiated block of cells,
it's only matter, why not deal with it?
As has been put to me by a
world-class gynecologist.
And I pointed out to her, I said,
"But you come to that
because of your atheism."
Now, I said to her, "What would you do?
"That's not only life after
conception, it's human life."
From where I sit it
bears the image of God,
what right have I to stop it?
So that the ethics are
worldview dependent.
And this is one of the huge problems,
way beyond that question.
You know, if we teach kids in school
that they are purely animals, full stop,
we'll see they start
to behave like animals.
And that's exactly what
we see in our society.
Knife crime in London has
just gone off the map.
But it's because people have been taught.
And you were talking about abortion,
these killing infants after birth
that's Peter Singer's
view and I've debated him.
And the issue stems
straight from his atheism.
And so I think we ought to be more upfront
about the connection
between some of these issues
and the worldview of the society around.
- If I could just add on that quickly.
I mentioned this equality forum
that the Democrats had last night.
And one of the things
that, it seems to me that
they're always trying to outdo themselves
and who can be the most
Left or the most progressive
or the most collectivist.
And you may have heard this last night
but Beto O'Rourke basically said,
the churches and places of worship
that aren't for same-sex marriage,
he would want them to
lose their tax exemption.
That's an absolutely absurd position.
But this why those of us, we can disagree
on these sort of margin issues
but we have to come together
around the freedom issue,
number one because will come next is that
they'll say all right, well now
if you're not completely pro-choice
you should lose your tax exemption.
And they will just keep encroaching
on every set of beliefs you have.
So I may not share that
exact belief with you
but I would 100% defend your
ability to have that belief
in the place that you
worship without question.
(audience applauding)
- Got one for you here, John.
And it's keeping on a sort of
pretty serious tack as well.
This person asks on the premise
that we are created in the image of God
and we each have value how do you respond
to the growing rate of
suicide in the West?
I think we're seeing
this especially among men
that suicide is increasing
at an alarming rate.
Where do you see that coming
from and how do you speak to it
as someone who does
believe people are made
in the image of God?
what does suicide have to,
what's the response I suppose,
to somebody who goes that route?
This is very complicated question
because suicides are all different.
I have a colleague
who's one of the world's
experts on suicide.
And just talking to him makes me realize
that this a very complex thing.
But just thinking about it simplistically,
people tend to commit suicide
when they have nothing to live for,
they've got no future that they can see.
And I do believe that the
Christian message addresses
that head-on by giving people that.
And I have personally seen people come
from the edge of suicide
and become settled,
balanced everything else
because they've come to faith in Christ.
And they've got that meaning
that has answered that
need to destroy themselves.
And the difficulty is, I'm too old now
to really understand the vicious effect
that Facebook for example,
likes and dislikes,
have on young people where
they get bullied in cyberspace
and they feel completely awful
and they lose all their self-worth.
I mean the cruelty that people exhibit
to one another is unbelievable.
And what's the answer to that?
Well the answer, I've
got to start with me.
I love Jordan's thing,
"Clean up your own room
"before you clean up the world."
And it needs to start with
me, the people I know,
looking for the signs of depression
or feeling down or feeling
lonely or feeling meaningless.
We can all do a little something.
It may not be much, it
may not hit the headlines
but it could take someone
back from the brink.
There's no universal answer to it.
- There is a follow-up
question that this has sparked
and has been coming in
which is what about the case
of believing Christians
who perhaps commit suicide.
And I think that has been
quite a significant case here
in Southern California recently.
- Well I know of one or
two very significant cases
of people I actually knew.
And I'm not a doctor,
I'm not a psychologist
but we've got to realize
that our minds can actually break down.
There used to be a time,
fortunately it's past,
where psychiatrists and
psychologists were looked upon
by many in the Christian
community with a lot of suspicion.
If you broke your leg,
you went to a doctor
and that was fine, everybody
thought that was fine.
But if your mind broke that wasn't fine.
And I think we've got to realize
that even to believing
Christians, they're still human.
They still have got
flaws and difficulties.
Your temperament doesn't change overnight,
you may have noticed, when
you become a Christian.
And if you haven't noticed that
you ought to wake up and notice it.
(audience laughing)
And therefore we can break down,
the chemical imbalance in our brain can go
and people jump off a
cliff or shoot themselves.
We need to be very careful
how we judge those people
because we don't see inside their mind.
And I want to say, okay this has happened,
it's tragic but don't judge
what was going on in their mind.
You've got to leave it to God ultimately.
(audience applauding)
- Can I just add to that?
I would just add one thing to that quickly
which is there's a
strange paradox right now
because we're more connected
than we've ever been, right?
We're all on Twitter
and Facebook and YouTube
and all these things and
we can connect with people.
And we can send pictures to people
and do all this stuff, right?
And it feels very connected.
And then on the other hand
the number one type of email
that I get is people that are
afraid to say what they think
and they say they watch my show
because they're afraid
to say what they think.
And I happen to be having
some of the conversations
that are the things that
they're thinking about.
And I suspect that if
you're walking around,
as most of us do probably everyday,
not really saying the
things that you're thinking
the end result of that
will be such a disconnect from reality
because all you've got
then left is your own mind.
And if you do that over and
over and over and over again
you got nothing left and I suspect
that would be the type of place
where there would be you could
see yourself having to make
that horrific choice because you're so--
- Connected versus not friendship>
- [Dave] Yeah.
- Yeah, absolutely, we've gone over
some pretty big issues tonight
and we've had many, many more questions in
than we can answer.
There's just one maybe which
kind of sums up the evening
to some extent that we've had
which is a question for
John referring today
which is, John, do you want
Dave to become a Christian?
(audience laughing)
- I really have to ask my agent
what the original pitch was.
(audience laughing)
- I don't choose, well,
the questions kind of
choose themselves here.
There so many people are basically asking,
hey, what, can you ask Dave
this question about Christianity.
So I had very little choice in the matter.
But yeah, I mean, I'm guessing
the answer is yes, John.
- You're not guessing.
(audience laughing)
Because I've experienced a
life which I don't deserve,
which has been full of profound joy,
a journey that has been
deeply meaningful to me
and it's connected with my
relationship with Christ,
of course not only Dave but everybody here
because there may be many skeptics here
and people watching online.
Of course, my desire
is that they can share
that experience that I
share and become Christians.
But, but, I'm not in the business
of browbeating people
and forcing them beyond where they are.
I feel very strongly
and that's why I believe
in public discussion.
Let's have the discussion on the table
from different points of
view but trust the people
to make up their own mind.
And so my motivation is
to get the message out
and leave the results with God.
But my desire is that,
of course it's that.
But don't specify Dave
alone poor chap. (laughs)
- Thank you, John.
- Just think of our
neighbors and our friends.
Is it our desire?
I think, when I'm asked
a question like this
I get very slightly nervous
because I want to relate
to people as whole persons
not just as evangelism fodder.
And that's very important.
(audience applauding)
Dave, you have been a
tremendous sport tonight
and I can only say,
you've been so gracious
and willing to engage with you know--
- Exactly.
- Occasionally being
browbeaten actually on this.
But I guess, you know, if we come
to just some final thoughts
at the end of our conversation now,
what for you has been the value
of having a conversation like this?
What for you, why do you sit
down, week in and week out
with people that you may
not necessarily agree with
on everything but you're interested
in finding stuff out from?
What's the value of these kind
of big conversations around culture, faith
and God in the end?
- Yeah, well first off, it
never struck me as so obvious.
You know, Jews don't
try to convert people.
That's made this doubly
funny for me, I think.
No, first off, just joking aside.
This has been an absolute pleasure.
You know, I have found that
when I am having an interview
with someone that is really real,
when we're suddenly hitting
some unchartered territory
or I can really see somebody
exploring a new idea
or not giving me the packaged answer
and we've really
connected in that deep way
that I can actually feel something.
And I really mean that.
I can feel a physical
reaction to that sort of warm,
I can't really fully describe it.
But it's not just something physical.
It's almost like, truly, it's almost like
I can see almost like
an aura around somebody.
And so this sort of a religious something
I guess I'm giving you.
But I can feel something
when something is truly real
and I think we all know those moments
when you sort of let all
of the other stuff go
and you're just having
something that's real.
There's something there.
However, you want to describe that.
I love being on this type of adventure,
this type of conversation,
this is exactly why I do what I do
because we desperately need it.
You know, there's been a, I think theme
throughout all of this beyond
the personal stuff to me
but I think theme really was
that there is a crisis of meaning
and we're all sort of realizing
that the world is in
complete flux right now.
The future feels like it's in flux.
I'm 43 years old I was born in '76.
At no point in my life,
until the last say two
years or three years,
did the world feel like it was in flux
like the future is actually confused.
Will America continue to
exist the way it exists?
Will the West continue to
The UK, I mean, you guys have all sorts
of crazy things going on.
- Oh yeah,
it's an interesting adventures for us too.
- Yeah, I mean I could
do an hour on Brexit.
We'll let that be.
That's more difficult than God.
(audience laughing)
- True.
- So many people are feeling that though
that sense of uncertainty.
And for the final Jordan
reference that I'll make tonight,
I mean he has been trying to
hand people a little bit of,
not a little bit, some of the tools
to make the world a little less uncertain
because if you can whole yourself first
then you can deal with
the rest of it, right?
So this an absolute, absolute pleasure.
And I will gladly have
you both on my show.
We can do this together or
we could do it separately
and we can continue these conversations
and more than anything
else what I would say is,
you know, for you guys here
I think there's a feeling
out there that if you listen
to the way the mainstream
frames everything
it's like somehow you
guys are the bad guys
or Christians are the bad guys
or conservatives are the bad guys
and this just sort of factory
setting boring dribble.
I know it's not true because
I'm in this room with you right
and I'm not gonna get
lynched on the way out.
(audience laughing)
Right, like we know that.
There's, yeah, yeah, I know I got it,
I got like a few people answer that.
He's not getting lynched, okay!
We know that right and I
think take confidence in that
and you know start saying what you think.
That's all that I'm doing, truly.
I'm talking to people
and interviewing people
but really all I'm really
doing is saying what I think.
And for some reason in
2019 in the freest country
in the history of the world
that's a special thing.
I have no idea why.
Well, I know why, but I don't
know why I don't fear it.
I just don't.
But I think if all of you started saying
what you think a little bit more,
you might find out that the
people that are your neighbors
and your friends and
even and your co-workers
and even your family members
who you disagree with politically,
you might actually start changing them.
But you'll never change them
if you don't say what you think.
So that would be my main
message more than anything else.
- Well done.
(audience applauding)
I think that's a great
place to draw it to a close.
So let me first of all
say thank you to John,
thank you to Dave for a really amazing,
very open, very honest
conversation tonight.
Thank you all for all
of your interactions.
The questions that came in,
sorry we couldn't get
to all of them tonight.
I just want to say a big thank you as well
to Calvary Chapel Costa
Mesa who have hosted us.
Can we give a big round of applause?
(audience applauding)
- If you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations
about spirituality
instead of non-stop yelling,
check out our spirituality playlist.
And if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist.
They're all right over here.
And to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and
click the notification bell.